alors quoi de beau bonjour à tous alors
quoi de beau ce week-end dans les
Yvelines alors déjà il fait très beau un
peu chaud là je le ressens j'espère que
le micro il est waterproof alors
normalement les chaleurs vont se
poursuivre tout le week-end mais en tout
cas sachez que samedi c'est la journée
internationale du tricot donc là il fait
vraiment chaud le tricot ça réchauffe je
sais pas pourquoi ils ont mis ça à cette
date là donc on va tricoter pour ce beau
samedi donc je vais rejoindre Brigitte
je sais à moi pour être tricoter tout ça
donc bonjour Brigitte vous faites du
tricot oui depuis plus de 40 ans ok un
peu d'expérience quoi un peu
et alors moi j'ai jamais commencé j'ai
jamais testé est-ce que là par exemple
je peux apprendre tout de suite et
devenir roi du Tricolore
un peu compliqué mais on peut regarder
les bases alors les aiguilles dépendent
de la taille du fil et le feu filet est
gros plus le numéro d'aiguille est gros
ok
je pense qu'on va se faire quelques
torsades
on teste
avec l'index mais dans le pouce
voilà
OK et
avec quel mot
est beaucoup plus simple en dessous il
faut tendre avec mais j'arrive pas à
attendre sur les deux
mais j'ai pas le hop moi
je vais te monter je vais
et là ça se voit que ça va vraiment vite
là
[Musique]
sur ton
aiguille là
j'ai pas le hop encore et comment tu as
appris ça toi Brigitte difficilement
parce que ben comme je te dis je suis
gaucher donc tout est pour les droitiers
avec une de mes tentes
il y a pas des ciseaux
dans la boucle
là il est passé là
donc si je fais rien
voilà
donc là j'ai tricoté à l'endroit regarde
ce que j'ai fait et après je prends du
coup celle-là là
j'ai arrêté de serrer j'ai arrêté de
tenir j'ai l'impression que l'histoire
du coup c'est une connerie et là
maintenant en fait c'est la troisième
main qui me manque vraiment
et là ça tricote ou quoi là
ça m'arrange pas du tout là et que je
vais mettre dans lequel dans ce cadre de
ma droite là
je l'avais presque
transpire Brigitte là oh là là
mais je sens que je suis pas loin mais
je vois pas comment je passe d'un fil
d'un fil en fil je l'ai perdu j'ai tout
perdu là
bam j'ai l'impression que c'était moi
qui font plus que les miennes quand même
là à la vache en fait j'ai compris je
crois le principe
je crois que j'ai fait ma boucle je l'ai
mis
en même temps
pour aller plus vite je fais deux par
deux mois